Okay.
We do have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David p two
one nine two.
David p.
Here's an interesting and completely sincere
question from a viewer.
Take a listen to this.
Hey David.
I'm wondering, um, when is the first time
you really, uh, questioned his sexuality and
uh, how did that come out?
Um, you know, uh, to, uh, to to I guess pat.
I mean, we'll be the first option.
Um,
how did he take that and we'll see responsible
or was he
a sort of immature?
Um, thanks.
Yeah, so have good, completely sincere question.
It's funny, by the way, obviously what they're
saying is, when did I start to question my
sexual orientation?
The answer being never.
When I was like five, I knew I liked girls,
but a lot of people say sexuality, which is
not sexual orientation.
The sex, if you actually look at the definition
of sexuality, it's something else.
And it's almost like a Freud Ian slip in a
sense where it's like you're not even really
asking me about what you think you're asking
me about.
Um, but in any case, pat took it all very
professionally.
I disclosed to pat during the hiring process
that, um, I am exclusively, uh, dating women
and Pat said that that was completely fine
and he was completely responsible and, and
professional in every way and we've had no
problems whatsoever.
Thank you so much.
Uh, shockingly, now this is, I, I hesitate
to even say this because I don't want to offend
people.
We, uh, we got back from vacation and I had
several hundred voicemails to go through to
see what could I use on today's show.
That was the best thing.
In terms of you, when I listened to the voicemails
I'm listening to, is there a funny or interesting
point, what's the caller's connection?
Like how long is the voicemail?
Some people leave a three minute voicemail
and then it maxes out.
That's the Max and then they call back and
say they need to add onto it.
Like have we ever played a five minute voicemail
on the show?
No.
Once I eliminated bad audio people that are
droning on and on and on, things that just
aren't interesting.
Unfortunately.
Some people who seem to maybe not be totally
well who call in regularly, I actually didn't
have that many short pithy interesting ones.
So you know that that's what we ended up with.
It's disappointing, but uh, alas, uh, such
as life and that's a, we're working with what
we've got.
That's all I can really do.
And yes, I know ag man, you sent a couple,
your audio was disastrous during them and
it was completely unusable in every way.
On today's bonus show, we will be talking
about my vacation to Aruba.
I will talk about the culture, I will talk
about the cuisine, I will talk about the geography.
I will talk about all sorts of other things
from my trip.
On today's bonus show, we will also hear from
producer Pat who went on.
I've deliberately not asked him anything about
it yet.
Pat was on, uh, another one of these road
trip extravaganzas.
This one, ideally short circuiting the car
trouble thing because instead of doing the
entire trip in a partially already broken
down van, um, he flew out and rented a car
for the beginning of the entire thing, national
parks, Vegas, all sorts of other stuff.
So I, I've heard nothing about it and we're
going to hear about it, uh, on the bonus show.
So if you don't have access to the bonus show,
become a member at www.joinpackman.comorbecomeapatronatpatrion.com/david
Pakman show both.
We'll give you instant access to the bonus
show.
If you're not going to see any of that stuff
because you're not a member or a patron, you
can see some of my vacation pictures and videos
on my Instagram page at David Dot pacman on
Instagram.
But listen, you're, you're really not going
to get the full scope of it from three pictures
and one video become a member, if not for
anything other
then hearing my vacation stories, which are
substantive disabled, I'll speak to you then
the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.